des stars ce sera une mission des coûts
dans les émission d'ardisson il ya
toujours des stars tiens c'est depuis la
première de double je regarde ce que
j'ai fait des chinois
david bowie stephan eicher polio oui il
est balèze ton carnet reste pas de la
meilleure des crêtes appétit cette année
à lombez moi c'est évidemment parce que
je suis plutôt spécialisée dans dans les
français rien
alors attention je crois au cul assez
géromois le normand est acquis non mais
c'est là j'ai plus grand chose parce que
j'ai tout échanger avec avec un copain
contrainte un autographe de patrick
bruel tu veux voir la garde
pourquoi tu dis ça brûle elle s'apprend
pas deux lots seront cannelle olemps
culé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à mesdemoiselles messieurs antenne 2 et
philips l'inventeur du compact disc vous
présente la nouvelle émission de thierry
ardisson
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
m
pourquoi
[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue aux
folies bergères pour double je
avant tout je voudrais vous remercier
chers téléspectateurs pour votre
fidélité 38,1 ça change de séries bons
donnant notamment le cas ce soir encore
il ya plein de magnifiques cadeaux
philips a gagné pour nos deux candidats
et pour vous chers téléspectateurs
ce pro de rigueur c'est là où la fortune
qui nous fait là pour jouer avec nous
deux super stars du grand écran ce soir
nous allons lui demander d'exécuter la
cascade la plus difficile de sa carrière
réfléchir pendant une heure rambo face à
lui les gadgets qu'ils le sortent
toujours des situations les plus
périlleuses l'aideront il a gagné ce
soir
enfin jeudi les drom l'aideront c'est
quand même un mec qui s'est tapé les
plus jolies pépées du monde james bond
10 mois le cas contre le crime que
l'actuel rambour qui à mon avis vivre
qui gagne aux points et six monarques
proposé de jouer dans son prochain film
j'accepterai s'il ya du viêt a buté je
suis partant tu vas aller voir
terminator 2 je prouverai film de [ __ ]
tu sais james key edith cresson a dit
qu'un anglais sur quatre était p17 fais
quoi moi je m'en fous je suis au service
secret de sa majesté
il ya un truc que j'ai pas bien compris
dans ton dernier james bond au nom de la
rose c'est qu'il y avait pas de gadgets
pas de gonzesses et été sapé en cure et
ça c'est pas pareil c'est un jazz band
spaghetti ah bon et quand tu vois ton
dernier remplaçant tu penses pas que tu
devrais reprendre du service
c'est vrai que quand on voit timothy
dalton on aurait bien que vous employez
à brest
des millions de français savoure chaque
jour son esprit bien parisien son sens
de l'humour et son ardeur au travail
suscite l'admiration de tous sains et
des trous l'alaska le nom de philippe
bouvard
[Musique]
dis moi finalement toi tu es un cynique
pas vous savez un dans une société
d'hypocrites le cynisme fini par être le
compte de la franchise ben oui est ce
que tu as déjà pensé à se suicider le
suicide c'est l'acte désespéré d'un être
qui ne fait plus confiance ni à la
guerre ni aux transports ni aux maladies
nyala nature autre chose et tu favorable
à l'abolition de la peine de mort
l'abolitionnisme c'est une mesure que
l'on a prises pour qu'un crime ne fasse
pas chaque fois deux morts et tu penses
quoi de l'évolution du métier de
journaliste ce que tu es journaliste je
crois en toi bouffe il aurait beaucoup à
dire mais bon faute de temps le
journaliste moderne doit choisir où
voire l'événement où le décrire il a
rarement le loisir de faire les deux je
suppose qu'il ya 20 ans tu voulais faire
la révolution
oui ben comme tous ceux qui ont 20 ans
puis après
bon bah quand on s'aperçoit qu'une
révolution n'abolit pas les privilèges
mais qu'elles se bornent à changer les
privilégiés et tu penses quoi de l'amour
tarifé bas beaucoup de bien parce que
les prostituées sont des dames qui ne
demande pas qu'on les invite à dîner
avant de passer à l'acte puis honneur à
la main d'oeuvre qualifiée
tout le monde parle de racisme mais pour
toi c'est quoi au juste le racisme basta
la fois un sentiment bas et un sentiment
en pratique puisque ça consiste à en
vouloir à des gens qui sont aisément
repérables et qui généralement sont plus
malheureux que soi
si tu devais donner une définition de la
civilisation
ben je dirais que selon qu'on se met un
anneau
dans le nez ou dans l'oreille on est un
sauvage ou civilisé as tu peur de mourir
enfin ce qui m'embête c'est que la mort
empêche d'aller à ces rendez vous du
lendemain crois tu re l'existence de
dieu
non dieu n'existe pas enfin il faut
faire semblant d'y croire parce que ça
lui fait tellement plaisir
vous connaissez
les admire depuis longtemps puis vous
avez écrit 30 livres dont vous dites que
ce sont plutôt des articles de 300 pages
oui ce genre est souvent et puis là d'un
seul coup vous nous montrez des maximes
personnelles que vous gardiez pour vous
secrètement et vous publiez sur le titre
de penser au cherche midi
alors si vous aviez une minute pour me
vendre seul et vous diriez quoi je
dirais que j'ai mis quarante ans à
l'écrire et que vous mettrez 40 minutes
elle lire ouais c'est pas mal comme je
vous sais très occupé vous dites que
vous n'êtes plus moraliste que moral ça
veut dire quoi
odst allure que la morale m'en fous mais
qu' il faut quand même expliquer aux
gens que la vie n'est qu'une énorme
bouffonnerie qu'on vit dans une société
d'obsédé d'hypocrite et qu' il faut se
méfier quoi surtout mais là je fais un
travail de salubrité publique
[Musique]
mais je le fais comme tout le monde
pourrait le faire à mon âge qu au nom de
l'ancienneté de l'expérience puis de
petites réflexions
imaginez un soir rentrez chez vous 2 qui
auriez-vous le plus peur il est tard il
fait nuit
g de sel dans votre grande maison de qui
il voue le plus peur de pascal sevran de
bernard tapie de jean-marie le pen
sevran basse j'aurais peur qu'on ne
vienne copains tapis il me reprendrai ma
baraque pour 1 franc et le pen qui
serait capable de me passer au brou de
noix pour prendre ma place répond je
préfère être seul vous avez bien votre
petit fils oui je vous proposais de
confier à trois personnes voie celle à
catherine lara dorothée surtout fois
dorothée
catherine lara je sais pas si elle
pourra tout lui apprendre à pêcher
vente chez là c'est pas mal parce
qu'elle pourrait lui expliquer comment
était la chanson au temps du muet si
vous aviez un accident très grave
oui et puis on est en 2100 vous serez
encore la chaussure on vous propose de
vous greffer un cerveau à rendriez celui
de laurent cabrol de patrick sabatier ou
de patrick roy
il ya un cas où l'organe nécessaire ne
figure pas donc je l'exclus sous le nom
de pas qui sait il reste plus de
donneurs
à peut-être celui de l'anc de roland
pardon de laurent cabrol en cabrol ah
oui oui oui
puis bon c'est moi c'est mon rêve depuis
des années faire la pluie et le beau
temps
je voulais démontrer une fois de plus le
nouveau tout paris est ce que vous
connaissez jil caplan
j'ai entendu parler avant oui on m'a
même dit que c'était quelqu'un qui était
intéressant et que jusque maintenant je
dirige un music hall parisien
c'est pour ça on va regarder un truc
sans une kaplan vous allez voir
[Musique]
j'y vais pas
sur la scène de l'olympia ce produit à
partir de ce soir la chanteuse jil
caplan dont la carrière récente et déjà
salué par les succès que l'on connaît
mais ce que l'on sait moins c'est que
gilles a une soeur jumelle séverine qui
lui est bien utile dans son quotidien
je veux être moi je vois les différences
qui existent entre nous parce que je
vois ce qui nous sépare je vois dans son
visa dans son visage ses skis et les
choses différentes des miennes mais les
gens en général ne vois pas du tout
c'est ça qui est typique des jumeaux en
fait leur sens on se ressemble beaucoup
toutes les deux et au départ j'avais
juste un rôle je tirais de manager ou
jeu centraliser toutes les informations
je tenais son planning et au fur et à
mesure que le temps a passé
gilles déteste tout ce qu'ils m'ont and
i télé cocktails et elle m'a demandé une
ou deux fois de la remplacer le même
après midi s'il ya un interview imiter
les affaires et un cocktail de ce soir à
19h chose que gilles ne peut pas faire
parce qu' elle ne peut pas se coupe en
deux pages intervient j'appelle la soeur
de gilles je me demande si je lui
demande pardon aussi lé livre ce soir là
je répond aux interviews parce qu'elle
me le demande et parce qu'elle joue
notre ressemblance tout ce qui tout ce
qu'elle n'aime pas faire à un moment
donné elle m'a demandé par gentillesse
de lui rendre service de le faire à sa
place depuis deux ans je vis avec ce
secret que j'ai du mal à assumer et
aujourd'hui ça me libère d'une angoisse
que j'ai j'ai en moi depuis deux ans et
ça me soulage vraiment beaucoup font à
aucun moment donné j'ai voulu j'ai voulu
me défiler c'était c'était c'était quand
même un jeu assez innocent qui vient
dans les interviews donc finalement là
j'apprends que c'était la soeur jumelle
bon moi ça m'écoeure un peu quand même
parce que c'est une forme de lâcheté
artistique pourquoi ne pas répondre soi
même est ce que ça va plus loin est ce
que ça va pas dans les disques aussi qui
chante il faudrait peut-être que le
public le sage
mais rassurez-vous la maison de disques
de jil caplan nous l'a promis
c'est bien elle et non sa soeur que ses
fans applaudiront ce soir sur la scène
de l'olympia
ces quatre langues h&m une folle rumeur
d'abord philippe bouvard à l'oreille ah
bon cela dit il ya eu les soeurs kessler
au lido ouais et je me souviens que
marcel amont était fiancé avec l'une des
deux et je savais jamais avec laquelle
il sortait alors maintenant pour vous
les faits avoue chez vous le temps de
jouer pour laisser à rambo et à james le
temps de réfléchir
on écoute david bowie avant son olympia
le 29 octobre
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu veux
c
oui cela
[Musique]
go
m
non
[Musique]
matin
un monde
[Musique]
tu peux aller
là où
c'est
ou pas
[Musique]
qui
yoplait la mi-mars kengo y avait là
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jil caplan tu caches est elle une soeur
jumelle rambo est ton avis c'est l'info
c'est de l'intox
à mon avis c'est un peu pourquoi vous
ressemblent trop parfaite
ah bon j'adore ça je le deviens rambo
certainement pas de la même façon un bon
nous devrons encore modeste et toi james
bond je dirais que 70 de la foule de
l'info mais je peux le dire maintenant
philippe m'a dit que c'était de l'intox
pourquoi parce que ça vous énerve
qu'elle fasse l'olympia avant bobino non
mais je pense que un secret comme ça
serait sera éventé il ya des confrères
qui rôde partout dans les coulisses des
indiscrets professionnels qui aurait
levé le lièvre depuis longtemps c'est
pour ça que je pense que c'est bientôt
actions ont été les premiers à les
ventes et alors là chapeau
bon ben on va voir à toi philippe
bonsoir sylvester j'espère que je devais
vous être agréable c'était de l'intox
bravo
alors d'un piqué le score ça fait 1 0
pour rambo puis je vais te dire s'il
m'aime rambo cm à réfléchir c'est hyper
encourageant pour sabatier
philippe tu as un commentaire à faire
n'allez pas ce soir à l'olympia j'ai
kaplan n'y est pas ne passez pas par la
case départ et ne touchait pas vingt
mille francs
plus sérieusement nous ne voulons pas
porter malheur âgées kaplan comme le dit
le proverbe
nous ne voulons pas vendre la mèche
avant d'avoir tué la peau de l'ours un
film fait passer un petit mot dont je ne
connais pas la teneur et qu'il me
demande de lire ils nous signalent il
vous signale que séverine kaplan se
produira jeudi prochain au centre
culturel lyssenko d'ivry-sur-seine rien
compris est ce que vous êtes pour le
mariage des prêtres entre whims est ce
la seule façon honnête d'emmener
quelqu'un à l'automne est bon on va voir
ce qu'en pensent les gens dans la rue
lebas fiche je comprends pas je vois je
vois pas pourquoi ils peuvent l'être les
juifs le sont les protestants leçon je
vois pas pourquoi compris vrai un homme
du désir d'aimer de la chair et autres
choses qui peuvent approfondir le désir
de vivre à deux
et encore mieux en communion quoi donc
vous êtes pour le mariage des prêtres
entre bien c'est entre eux le marielle
de présenter non alors là l'eau non
c'est moins beau vous pensez qu'il est
mieux qu'il continue de se cacher que
les prêtres se fâche se cache cache leur
amour je préfère oui si je connaissais
un prêt qui ont qui était un peu plus
rapprochée que les autres mais j'avais
quand j'avais 12 ans epoté un petit peu
par un prêtre les mains ouais ouais mais
bon c'est
ouais ouais ouais mais non mais c'est
contradictoire la vocation on a mis
françois au mariage mais cette époque
avec lui allons y à mon nom c'était
comme un père j'ai passé ma mais non à
faire un petit peu assez ce que tu peux
tu pour aucun mariage quels qu'ils
soient
pourquoi donc vous êtes pour l'union
libre en ce qui concerne les prêtres ah
oui de chacun fait ce qui lui plaît
lorsqu ils s'aiment oh écoutez qu'on me
raconte les histoires de surcroît
comment le mariage des prêtres entre eux
oh my home à monseigneur qui en pince
pour un autre monseigneur même vous avez
déjà eu une relation une relation
sexuelle avec un prêtre et les soeurs
entre l appareil et les écuries et les
soeurs c'est ça doit se faire sur vent
comme dans tout bon
les curés les bergers allemands
dis toi philippe quand j'étais plus
jeune et que je regardais samedi soir à
la télévision
j'avais un rêve c'est d'être un jour
assis à côté de vous sur un canapé et
que vous mmes interviewé des gaves tepa
chez chapier là je sais que vous
reprenez d'ailleurs dans votre bouquin
la phrase de reboot val qui dit que
finalement quand un journaliste
intervieweuse journaliste est un peu
comme danser avec sa soeur je sais mais
posez moi quand même deux trois
questions
comme vous avez en face de vous jeune
femme très belle
est-ce qu en lui posant des questions
sur son métier sur sa famille pensait à
autre chose
jamais jamais jamais ça m'est jamais
arrivé vous ça vous arrive et vous non
je suis comme vous menteur
et à je voudrais savoir si vous
connaissez vous vous préoccupez de
connaître les réponses aux questions que
vous allez poser
oui en général quand je pose une
question je connais la réponse donc vous
savez quand on vous dit pas la vérité
voilà les jours à lens faisait ça je
faisais ça aussi alors quand vous êtes
fait virer d'antenne 2 par jean michel
gaillard et philippe guillôme le même le
même jour que vous à ce moment là vous
avez j'ai rien déclaré je suis le seul à
avoir rien dit vous avez déclaré c'est
une bande de zozos
non c'est pour éviter de leur faire de
la peine il était viré eux on savait
qu'il ferait rien d'autre de notre vie
fallait pas de trop méchant avec le dit
matt monte ou baisse en ce moment tant
donné l'heure il ya déjà pas mal de gens
qui vont se coucher
j'ai même l'impression que les gens qui
nous regardent sont moins habillée qu'au
début de notre conversation violence des
passants regardent un sujet sur
l'audimat
regardez bien cette puce électronique
expérimentale
il s'agit des styles ya une invention
japonaise qui pourrait bien
révolutionner le monde de la télévision
demain s'il est intégré dans tous les
téléviseurs elle pourrait devenir la
première mesure automatique d'audience
il ya deux catégories de personnes
intéressées à connaître l'audience de la
télévision elle est responsable de la
télévision parce qu'ils veulent savoir
s'ils réussissent à intéresser le public
évidemment et d'autre part les gens de
publicité qui veulent savoir combien de
gens regarderont les spots qu'ils vont
payer naturellement très cher à la
télévision
le système utilisé le plus couramment
est un système dit ou des métriques
on peut savoir dans un échantillon de
foyers de gens à qui on a demandé s'il
acceptait de recevoir cette boîte à la
fin de la journée
à quel moment le poste a été allumée sur
quelle chaîne à quel moment on se sont
situées des changements de chaîne et
c'est dans l'ancien système les sondés
étaient des volontaires mais les
industriels japonais voudrait imposer
aux européens un nouveau système
beaucoup plus indiscret aux téléviseurs
modernes en plus maintenant intégré des
cartes supplémentaires et sur ses cartes
on peut placer des composants comme ceux
qui vont servir pour rester un système
américano japonais et qui recrée en fait
une véritable intelligence artificielle
la machine est capable de s'initier
il est tout seul grâce à ses capteurs
sonores infrarouge et radars elle va
pouvoir connaître le nombre de personnes
qui se présentent dans la pièce leur
attitude leur façon de regarder la
télévision voir si c'est un enfant qui
marche à quatre pattes et ensuite se
redresse donc ça n'est pas un chien
alors c'est un système extraordinaire
parce que les informations repartent
vers un central par le fils électriques
qui sert à alimenter la télévision en
énergie et donc personne ne peut savoir
qu'il est espionné et pourtant ça sera
le cas et oui il s'agit bien là
d'espionnage et après la commission
européenne de bruxelles c'est la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés qui s'inquiète saisie du
dossier elle devrait prochainement
publier un rapport qui d'après nos
informations ne devraient pas être
favorable il en va en effet de la vie
privée des téléspectateurs peut-être
demain
big brother dans nos téléviseurs
automatique
philippe bouvard à l'oreille et de ce
mot ouais
alors maintenant pour vous laisser le
temps chez vous de réfléchir de taper
sur notre militaire pour laisser à rambo
et à james bond le temps de réfléchir à
leur réponse
on va écouter patrick juvet
et
[Musique]
car trop de désir parasites augmentation
qui me harcèle m16 a pas lâché mais
dément
qu'à transformer satellite est un
sion à des plaisirs illicites
moi j'ai jamais su dire non
c est fait
ils vont tenter de beaucoup la jambe
gauche chivu gaston au saut j'en ai
marre
à
oh
trop de détours et de fuite par
appréhension de l'amour et des suites
mais je suis quand même en prison
devant le bar où j'habite nick éléments
non c'est le mode par ces chiffres
on est presque au diapason
que sur le carreau des idées mégalo et
donc deux jours à meaux
j'en ai marre
t
j'en ai
[Musique]
je vais bonsoir bonsoir alors avant de
passer à des questions plus personnelles
souhaite demander si à ton avis tu crois
qu'un jour les gens rapidement vont être
contrôlés par un audimat automatique
c'est l'info c'est de l'intox
à mon avis malheureusement si ces
deux-là ainsi c'est de l'info ça risque
de lymphome et c'est vraiment sur sa
triste quand un dossier de presse on dit
que c'est son grand retour après dix ans
parce que tout ça c'était 4 71 80 après
81 81 ans comptait pas beaucoup vu mais
en fait tu as quand même essayer de
faire quelques comme ben et dix
dernières années moi je t'ai vu en 87
avec la marée mais j'ai fait des
tentatives de tentatives de come back
est pendante active et c'était pas un
moment où j'allais très bien dans le
coup je me disais c'est pour ça que je
dis à tout le monde si c'est les gens
qui m'écoutent qu'il faut être patient
c'est très long que ce soit sur moi
c'était l'alcool mais ça peut très bien
être autre chose la drogue pour les
autres je ne sais rien et que pour son
importante c'est très long donc il ya eu
des moments où je me sentais tellement
bien jeter europe on recommence
et si ce n'est pas encore le bon moment
c'est aujourd'hui le bon vin ça a l'air
c'était quoi le pire moment quand tu
étais dans l'alcool dans la dans la
grande foule était là dedans c'était
quoi le moment le plus difficile
il y en a eu plusieurs
vous y remettre je veux dire le pire ça
a été quand j'ai vraiment arrêter je
suis resté deux ans en angleterre pas
qu'on ne pas être dérangé par les gens
que je qui me reconnaissent elles s
étaient pas incité pas du star system
simplement parce qu'il ya un moment où
il faut se retrouver tout ça elle la
maman s'est tu pleures tu pleures tu
sais pas pourquoi je fais je souhaite à
personne
ça s'est passé comment comment tu t'es
était rentré là n'en dans le national
l'agglo lèvres pousse à agir montrer
comment maintenant ça s'est passé dans
la foulée dans le sens où plus à marcher
plus j'avais besoin de déplacer juin
j'ai eu la chance que ça marche aux
états unis we have américain millions
trois albums c'est pas mal donc on m'a
dit demain tu pars tu pars en espagne en
allemagne ou en angleterre cela partout
et je crois que physiquement je sais pas
tenu le coup vu un gie carburant veut
porter bien faire nominer au but
moi j'avais pris un poids énorme qui
fait que maintenant je me suis retrouvée
je pense que je vais bientôt avoir enfin
l'image qu'on voit dans son générique
pour moi et en mes sorties comment je
m'en suis sortie je crois qu'il fallait
donc c'est pas de gloriole c'est le vin
c'est pas du tout soit demandé aux gens
c'était de l'intox ou d'un faux
info parce que c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut il faut il faut faire un choix un
certain moment je vais pas en plus
j'avais même pas le choix parce que le
regard des faits condamnés à t'en sortir
ouais t'as un bon 10 et on est sûr que
ça va marcher on est content de te
retrouver la fête merci
ortelli vous avez bien connu patrick
juvet non quand il était au rwanda alors
ça ça remonte
oui oui c'était bien
oui vous avez été témoin en tant que
journaliste de ses frasques nombreuses
et variées
je pense je crois que je te comme tous
les juifs plutôt neutre ouais alors jen
c'est à toi de jouer
tous les téléspectateurs bientôt
contrôlé par l'audimat automatique s de
l'info ouest de l'intox
je crois que c'est de l'intox ah bon
pourquoi on soit pas vrai quand même un
peu aberrant
sur le plan moral oui mais oui pourquoi
comme disait mon sauveur les gens sont
plus que des habits à dans ce domaine ah
oui enfin connaître les séquelles
sexuelle d'une émission s'intéresse en
russie des ordinateurs et toi en bon moi
je pense que c'est parlant de l'intox
mais les alims je souhaite parce que ça
deviendrait quand même grade de savoir
ce que regardent les gens ça peut être
intéressant de malheurs de la savoir qui
est devant la télé qui fait quoi
ça devient dangereux intox intox
maintenant je peux le dire vous magique
c'est vrai ouais dit que c'est vrai il
ya un procédé qui s'appelle motive ac
qui n'a d'ailleurs pas été agréée pour
l'instant mais qui permet de voir si les
téléspectateurs vont et viennent dans
une pièce et tous les téléspectateurs
bon écoute et on va voir on écoute
philippe guérin est de l'info est de
l'intox philippe big brother dont le
poste
on le dit bien tous les téléspectateurs
ça ne pouvait être que de l'intox dur
j'ai pas bien écouté alors ma fille le
score du score ça fait 2 1 pour rendre
boer à propos fais gaffe parce que tout
à l'heure je faisais mes courses dans le
quartier je suis tombé sur rambo jeudi
pardon ne seriez pas où il ya un arabe
ouvert dans le quartier va déboucher pas
je vous en ai ouvert un tout de suite je
danse
tu as un commentaire à faire witi rire
des mois bien regardez moi bien je vous
propose une petite expérience pour
vérifier si les méthodes actuelles de
mesure d'audience sont exactes vous
aller décrocher votre téléphone appelez
vos parents amis maîtresse voisins
ennemis enfants chiens
tout le monde vous allez leur demander
de quitter la chaîne qu'ils regardent
actuellement je répète de quitter la
chaîne qu'ils regardent actuellement
pour venir nous rejoindre
si ça marche je ne manquerai pas de vous
le signaler la semaine prochaine si ça
ne marche pas je ne manquerai pas de
vous le signaler aussi la semaine
prochaine
merci bravo bravo voilà quelqu'un qui
sait parler
4 heures une bonne méthode finalement
est ce que vous aimez les histoires
belges
oui beaucoup vous en connaissez une
comme ça les gens j'en connais
50 c'est pourquoi quand il ya un mariage
chez les belges on met du fumier devant
la sur le parvis de l'église moment de
la sortie du portage c'est pour toutes
les mouches n'at il pas sur le marié et
bien je vous en montrer une autre voie
si le magazine du faux
[Musique]
ça pourrait être l'histoire banale d'une
arrivée de marathon comme celle ci dure
et pathétique mais c'est l'histoire dab
est et amis qui a franchi la ligne
d'arrivée du dernier marathon de
bruxelles fringant heureux mais sous les
sifflets nous sommes le 15 septembre
1991 lors du huitième marathon
international de bruxelles
l'algérien tes amis revêt au départ le
dossard numéro 62 remarqué que l'homme
porte une jolie moustache quinze
kilomètres plus loin le dossard numéro
62 est toujours dans la course mais
surprise son propriétaire est rasé de
près et n'a plus tout à fait la même
tête
la supercherie est toute bête ce visage
imberbe c'est celui du vrai tes amis
pour économiser ses forces il a laissé
courir son entraîneur et l'a remplacée
avant l'arrivée mais la moustache leur
fut fatal
malgré les 250 mille francs de prix
l'entraîneur n'avait pas accepté de la
sacrifier
c'est vrai qu'une moustache c'est
précieux c'est bien l'opinion du
soviétique kharitonov le vrai vainqueur
de cette épreuve
[Musique]
drôle d'histoire belge ne vous y croyez
pas et c'est de l'info ça te retrouves
c'est gros mais ça s'est il ya pas de
problème ça c'est pas un sujet info ou
intox
c'est incroyable s'est formé vous
travailler 15 heures par jour vous avez
six secrétaires vous avez six chauffeurs
mais non non combien de chauffeur un
chauffeur et un chauffeur aussi bien la
peine de ce défi tous malboeuf au lait
cru mais cinq ce créateur temps avait
quand même vous avez des [ __ ] non non
non non non non tout moment bah oui je
suis méfiant êtes vieux jeu quand même
vous possédez quoi au juste
une belle maison en bonne santé
c'est apparemment un dirty mm à tous
crins il vaut mieux vérifier à lui
d'accepter des invitations comme la
vôtre allongement tirera toujours et on
vous dit je mentirais toujours vous
parler des filles du public
vous avez des actions en bourse
non mais des banques sont acquises
c'est un auteur d'un style de ce type là
non mais j'en ai eu
puis bon ben j'ai compris que la
spéculation qui n'était pas intellectuel
n'était pas mon fallu renoncer mais
beaucoup plénier toujours de payer trop
d'impôts en fait vous payez pas encore
les gens qui viennent comme vous
finalement non je me suis jamais plaint
de payer trop d'impôts je me suis plaint
que l'on soit pas gentil avec moi quand
je les paye et je paye toujours à
l'heure et au jour dit depuis longtemps
et 2 qu' on envoie mon argent plus mal
que je ne le ferai
ouais vous plaignez quand c'est la
droite au pouvoir quand c'est la gauche
au pouvoir dont inalement votre aroui
jamais oui alors que jamais au sérieux
je sais que je ne serai jamais osé mais
l'ennui avec la gauche il y avait valeur
et que le centre n'existant plus râleurs
rouspète rouspéter rend ses moyens mais
charaf vous a pas collé un contrôle
fiscal pour vous calmer pas non non non
sharon que c'est rigolo
vous étiez plutôt chirac jusqu'à ce que
vous rencontriez mitterrand et vous
parliez de jules renard et de flaubert
avec lui et ça vous a fait changer
d'avis l'aifa prof de lettres non non
mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu des
conversations littéraire l'a fait
passionnante
avec monsieur françois mitterrand mais
c'est indépendant de toute politique on
peut avoir de la sympathie pour un homme
vous avez 62 ans oui pourquoi continuer
ma ba oui pourquoi
peut-être à cause de celui dont vous
avez cité le nom à cause d'un char en ce
cas ci comprendrait pas que je m'arrête
vous dis toujours je fuis quelque chose
mais au fond c'est puisque vous fuyez
maintenant si je fuis le chômage en
travaillant maintenant que j'ai laissé
tomber le poker c'est moins besoin
d'argent quand même ah oui beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins ça vous coûte et
chaud ce truc là ça me coûtait très
chaud je perdais mon argent
mon temps mes nerfs mais nuit et mes
amis qui devrait du client c'est vrai
que vous étiez fait interdire en france
et vous aviez joué à l'étranger
séditieux ça quand même
alors ça vous coûte encore plus cher
parce que y'a le voyage on va voir un
truc justement ce jour l'auteur anonyme
oui allez voir aujourd'hui beaucoup de
français résiste mal aux facilités de
crédit offertes par les banques et les
organismes de prêt accro à la carte
bleue ils sont saisis d'une forte fièvre
acheteuse est sombre inexorablement dans
le surendettement pour les aider une
association les débiteurs aux anonymes
vient de se créer à paris à l'église
américaine sur le modèle des alcooliques
anonymes
le général de ce type d'association lit
des gens qui ont tous eux mêmes
problèmes entre eux se réunissent pour
réapprendre à nouveau comportement avec
l'argent alors c'était fait j'en ai je
dit qu'ils sont par exemple de tenir à
jour
argy de ses dépenses et
on n'est pas dans le but de budgétiser
mais vraiment dans le but d'apprendre à
faire face toutes ses qualités de
l'argent qui peut organiser des réunions
de ce qu'on appelle des réunions de
décompression est vraiment de mettre
tout simple à doser en parler en sachant
que les personnes à qui on m'en parle
ont connu le même problème que donc en
parler en déculpabilisant maximum quand
on rencontre les débiteurs d'anonymes on
peut se demander s'ils font pas partie
d'une secte un petit peu parce qu'il ya
quand même un embrigadement il ya un
jargon il ya des mots qui reviennent
souvent un peu du lavage de cerveau quoi
alors effectivement ils ont douze
commandements ton premier et
l'abstinence
quoique on leur dit qu'on leur dise pas
de jeter leur carte de crédit leur
chéquier terrain lors des fêtes des
dettes mais si vous pouvez les
remboursements c'est pas du tout une
secte s'est fait qu'il va en faire appel
à une puissance supérieure que chacun
peut avoir au fond de soi est vraiment
une puissance supérieure tels que chacun
conçoit qui peut être finalement le bon
sens qui peut être la partie saine que
donc que tout individu a en lui et
apprendre vraiment servir de cette
partie scène justement pour faire face à
ce problème de rythme parce que
sportivement c'est un problème je crois
d'ordre mental secte pas c'est qd je
sais pas mais il parle beaucoup de dieu
lors c'est un petit peu inquiétant si
c'était politisé je crois que ce serait
carrément dangereux alors dit on revient
tout le temps et a par exemple la fin de
chaque séance les hipsters anonymes se
réunissent comme ça en rond d'estienne
la main et récite une prière que j'ai
sous les yeux je vous lis mon dieu
donnez-moi la sérénité d'accepter les
choses que je ne peux changer le courage
changer les choses que je peux et la
sagesse d'en connaître la différence
amen
modèle des alcooliques anonymes philippe
bouvard à l'oreille et doucement ouais
ah bon alors maintenant pour laisser un
rambo et à james le temps de réfléchir
on écoute ta cheval dans ma bulle
amène à brisbane stanley et un membre de
la retenir
bawara maire sait
aubry
[Musique]
star
et
mais n'empêche pas qu'une star
la mairie
[Musique]
comme atypique
de tout
tu te sentirais comme à tbb porno
randonnée
et
[Musique]
nous nous soutenir mais leurs parents ma
mère
[Musique]
le
et
[Musique]
d
batista
m
je me suis toujours demandé
ma
à menchhoffen
[Musique]
et
et au lieu de soutenir le maire
[Musique]
et
une ascèse
sur le modèle des alcooliques anonymes
rambo et toi tu joues s de l'info est de
l'intox on t'écoute
il me fait peur ils sont plutôt lui pas
vous du rire et de l'intox
oui james aussi anatoxine donc je peux
le dire maintenant nous avons trois
intox autour de nous il y avait un qui
doit se lécher les babines
c'est notre expert philippe guérin je me
laisse pas du tout les babines je vais
carrément la trouille sylvester
excuse-moi james excusez moi philippe
excusez moi c'est de l'info je remarque
quand même mon cher bouvard oui vous
plantez pour la deuxième fois et ça nous
fait très plaisir malin non mais c'était
drôlement bien fichu ouais ça va les
gars pons avait l'air d'une blague
oui oui oui en plus alors je vais vous
dire maintenant pourquoi j'ai dit que
c'était de l'intox et des grands fonds
là je vous donne tout ce qu'il faut pour
m'enfoncer davantage j'ai cru que
c'était faux est-ce que j'en avais
jamais entendu parler est-ce que tu n'es
rien préfet tient et oui alors bâti le
score le score était toujours de 1 pour
rambo tout à l'heure tu disais que jones
monde s'était attiré les plus belles
nanas de la terre ce soir c'est pas
évident qui tire son épingle du jeu
philippe est ce que tu as un commentaire
à faire là-dessus c'est de l'info il
existait les alcooliques anonymes il
existe un certain nombre d'associations
de drogués anonymes ou d'anciens
toxicomanes aide les drogués à décrocher
on attend aujourd'hui avec impatience
une nouvelle association qui pourrait
s'appeler les téléspectateurs anonyme
d'eau la présidence pourrait être
confiée à notre ami pierre carles qui a
été viré ya une quinzaine de jours par
mougeotte de tf1 parce qu'il en avait
trop dit pas mougeotte pierre carles
cette association pourrait permettre à
un certain nombre de téléspectateurs de
décrocher des émissions les plus débiles
on avis ça va être dur voyez quelle
chaîne qui veut dire pas du tout ça je
sais pas mais je sais que les
téléspectateurs anonyme ça existe avant
ces mêmes qui écrivent au directeur de
la chaîne où vous travaillez
généralement mairie est ce que vous vous
vexer facilement vous connard
et on se vexe quand on comprend alors il
ya parfois un petit décalage bon parce
qu'il ya une rubrique dans cette
émission qui s'appelle costard de stars
ou en taille des costumes aux stars vous
promet d'être pas vous vexer non plus
sinon je me cache alors on regarde le
costard de stars
monsieur que pensez-vous de philippe
bouvard
je n'aime pas beaucoup à votre avis
vieux croûtons c'est parce qu'il est
petit qu'il est agressif
j'en sais rien il n'est pas agressif la
taille n'a rien à voir là dedans ou
vieux débris les personnes petit ne sont
pas forcément agressive du tout pas du
tout a dit le elles sont pas du tout
agressif pas forcément comme les autres
comme les grandes
nous avons trouvé agressif que la
populaire un peu mais c'est pas grave il
y bouvard eux j'en ai pensé beaucoup de
choses et puis plus grand chose j'sais
pas pourquoi je sais pas j'ai regardé
quelques voix je trouve que c'est un
humour d'accord mais pas de grandes
volées à votre habit à votre habit
vieille peau c'est parce qu'il est petit
qu'il est agressif au alors s'envoler
une question de très importantes
il bougeait pas la journée non plus un
pardon dépêchez vous de répondre oui je
pas monsieur que pensez-vous de philippe
bouvard du mal du mal beaucoup de mal
pourquoi c'est long ce sera long à dire
penser que c'est parce qu'il est petit
qu'il est agressif âge avait jamais
pensé qu'il était petit savais pas qu'il
était petit fayt mandibules qu'il répond
j'ai pas que ça à [ __ ] non plus il est
petit vous allez vous faire [ __ ] à
villevieille morue c'est parce qu'il est
petit qu'il est agressif
non rien à voir il va russe et pour lui
c'est pour moi c'est pour vous beau
merci on sait que c'est parce qu'il est
petit qu'il est agressive cancon oui je
pense oui bah oui je pense mais bah
ouais là la preuve
combative connard ouais vous pensez que
les petits sont forcément agressive
connard non abruti
est ce que vous êtes agressif parce que
vous êtes petit par non non non en quad
subsume peut-être que si j'avais eu un
mètre 90 sur a été plus sympa cela dit
c'est pas très crédible parce que
j'avais quand même 30 cm de plus que
vous payez dites moi philippe en mars 81
vous avez poursuivi un journaliste de
paris abdou qui s'appelait jean michel
caradec parce qu'il avait écouté vos
conversations téléphoniques depuis votre
voiture et vous l'avez quand même
demandé trente mille francs de dommages
et intérêts oui attendait alliés quelque
chose à cacher non mais non seulement il
avait écouté ce que ce que je disais
leur mort a dit au téléphone mais encore
il avait publié dans un journal qui
d'ailleurs qu'il n'ya pas celle qui
arrête mais d'autres raisons et j'ai
trouvé que bon comme le je suis un
téléphone aux maniaques et que le radio
téléphone et dans nos types de métiers
et nos genres de vie un instrument
primordial il fallait créer une
jurisprudence qui protège les usagers et
ça a été fait c'était une conversation
strictement ces bonnes âmes ce n'est pas
une aventure même c'était exactement
privée je parlais d'un tas de copains
bon il y en a que je traitais bien
d'autres que je traite est moins bien et
devoirs huit jours plus tard c'est
imprimé sa touche au dans la journal
ccma agréable pour les copains non plus
le baiser de mariés depuis 37 ans oui
est ce qui vous arrive de céder à la
tentation après 37 ans de mariage au bas
de moins en moins étant donné mon
avantage
vous avez bien que ça vous est jamais
arrivé de céder à la tentation rôle du
port ce que je tiens à rester dans les
limites d'une certaine vraisemblance
vous avez déjà flashé sur une hôtesse de
l'air qui me faisait sourire commercial
vous avez pris ça pour une avance vous
et je il ya une bonne histoire comme ça
tant que citoyen je crois que c'est dans
un avion d'une compagnie israélienne
l'hôtesse demande un passager israélien
son nom qu'elle comprend pas bien son
nom et lui dit vous mais pelé vous mais
voulait aussi est ce qu'on peut voir ce
soir oui c'est bon maintenant vous êtes
qu'ils ont trouvé un truc pour les
hôtesses
c'est ce qu'ils font là vous allez voir
regarder elles vont sentir moins
mauvaise hygiène maximum dès le saut du
lit pour se protéger de soi comme de
l'autre voici le sous-vêtement anti
bactéries après le tissu anti tâches et
la combinaison de ski anti-froid voici
le 10e bactéricide qui élimine toute
odeur corporelle et vous assure une
haute protection contre les
contaminations se te fibre va pouvoir
permettre de lutter contre les mauvaises
odeurs de tous produits reportés à même
la peau donc la chemise les
sous-vêtements la chaussette et de
lutter contre tout développement
bactérien sur les textiles que l'on
rencontre dans les lieux collectifs
je le sois l'hôtel l'hôpital l'avion ou
le train
nous avons établi une collaboration avec
l'institut pasteur pour tester les
propriétés antibactériennes toutes les
applications faites en textile à partir
de notre fille bhl ce qu'il ya de plus
de plus typique ce sont les chaussettes
et bien dans les chaussettes de l'armée
par exemple qui dégageait tous deux
toujours d odeur épouvantable
le problème était le même les pieds
transpirent mais de la sueur avec de
lure émettent également des dépôts de
kératine venant de la peau les bactéries
bon manger cette kératine vont manger
saturé et dégager les odeurs selon
telles bactéries
vous aurez telle odeur
neudorf et canaux d'une odeur durée une
odeur de pied de chambre ait gardé
certains cols de chemise le soir vous
verrez qu'ils sont gras des bactéries
qui adore les graisses du corps humain
qui sont déposés sur ces cols de chemise
si la fibre et bactéricide le jem se
déposera sur la fibre et ne se
multipliera pas parmi les autres
applications envisagées un chemisier
destiné au personnel de swissair serait
aux dires de certains fabricants de
textile antibactérien en cours de
développement
c'est un tissu qui est absolument comme
n'importe quel autre tissu on ne perçoit
absolument aucune différence
si ce n'est le confort au bout de
quelques heures mais la compagnie suisse
connue pour ses exigences en matière
d'hygiène et de sécurité dément
catégoriquement ce projet
pas facile de prendre en filature une
chemise qui ne laisse pas d'odeur voilà
des chemisiers anti-odeurs à l'étude
pour les hôtesses de la swiss heures
philippe bouvard à l'oreille vous ça va
de la douceur c'est à dire juste de
jouer
info intox on vous écoute moi j'ai oryx
zinfos de l'info pourquoi vais-je très
sûr de vous mon cher à ceux toujours
agréable de sentir quelqu'un qui serait
beau mais ça d'accord mais est ce que
c'est de l'info c'est de l'intérêt même
aujourd'hui c'est de l'info de la focus
hambourg je dirais que c'est de l'info
aussi c'est tellement fou encore ce
titre voire la seule à l'est plus c'est
fou puisqu'il fait vous dites que ces
deux là oui parce qu'on vit dans un
monde fou de foot on a fait trop
tendance en gagner en avion tendance à
dire que c'est faux donc vous philippe
vous m'avez dit que c'était de l'intox
oui j'y crois pas vous y croyez pas
pourquoi rampe parce que je trouve que
c'est trop beau que puis encore une fois
je lis tout ce qui paraît qu'une telle
information mais t'échapper ça me paraît
un peu gros mais mais là ce possible
y'est j'ai peur pour vous un peu on va
écouter philippe guérin notre expert
vas-y phillips et d'infos c'est de
l'intox
hélas philippe aïe aïe aïe hélas aïe aïe
aïe applaudissez le quand même puisque
c'est de l'info
vous avez quoi comme journaux des
journaux où on parle pas de ça va
falloir jeu je change de titre bon le
score baffie le score ça fait 3 2 pour
rambo et puis pour revenir là-dessus il
n'y a pas que les élèves qui sont
mauvais parce que parfois même le poil
pubien figure philippe alors est ce que
tu as un commentaire à faire et oui mon
cher philippe bouvard c'est de l'info
vous auriez dû vous en doutez à l'époque
du camembert sans saveur des frites sans
odeur et des dessous de bras sans moteur
le tissu sans odeur ça pourrait faire
peur
malgré tout dans certains cas pour des
personnes de taille moyenne ou petite
qui passent leurs journées à la hauteur
des et celle de leurs concitoyens ce
tissu pour être est très pratique
bien sûr mon cher philippe dire parce
que quand même il a oublié le problème
que moi mon ma véritable angoisse c'est
que en raison de cette petite taille
qu'il évoquait j'ai les pieds qu'ils
sentent la brillantine et l'onu qu'ils
sentent le cirad et là je me demande si
le nouveau produit pourra faire quelques
faits
philippe vous qui êtes un grand
confesseur devant l'éternel vous
arrive-t-il de vous confesser n'ont
jamais non enfin là aussi j'ai pas dit
mon dernier mot
mais c'est le cas de le dire on y va
venez vous confesser
et
[Musique]
philippe vous vous présentez souvent
comme un tiki né à montmartre en fête
est née à coulommiers
vous avez honte de votre lieu de
naissance non mais comme je suis partie
de coulommiers alors vu six mois ça m'a
pas tellement influencée en revanche
j'ai passé toute mon enfance et toute
mon adolescence sur la butte montmartre
dont j'ai d'ailleurs que vous pouvez le
constater gardé l'accent
vous avez une de vos origines sociales
non pas du tout d'ailleurs
elles sont modestes n'est digne il est
quoi votre papa mon papa est le
directeur d'une petite société
ma maman était opticienne vous avez dit
je me suis longtemps et il s'est passé
quoi depuis je me suis réconcilié avec
moi parce que je ne pouvais pas faire
autrement mais c'est vrai que j'aurais
voulu être autrement physiquement
autrement intellectuellement
d'être plus pure plus dur et que à la
longue on fini par dresser le répertoire
de tous ses défauts et que dans le même
temps les qualités si elles existent
vous apparaissent moins on peut pas
prendre en grippe quelqu'un avec qui on
est condamné à vivre jusqu'à la fin et
de surcroît quelqu'un qui vous nourrit
aussi bien vous avez peur de rien j'ai
eu peur de grossir ce que j'ai vu que je
m'en accommode eh bien on je voudrais
pas devenir énorme mais c'est pas
mauvais d'être enveloppé quand on fait
un métier public c'est inspire confiance
à la clientèle vous avez fait
trente-cinq mille interview à peu près
et celle que vous avez préféré c'est
celle de lanza del vasto pourvoir 3
parce que c'était un philosophe qui
avait mis en accord
c'est rarissime c'est ses pensées et ses
actes c'est à dire qu'il prêchait le
dénuement et il vivait lui même dans une
communauté qu'il avait monté dans le sud
de la france et qui fonctionnait comme
aux premiers temps du monde
je veux dire sans aucune des ressources
du programme ils filaient lui même le
lin dont il fabriquait ses vêtements
c'est une espèce d'âge d'or et puis j'ai
vu grâce à lui quelque chose que je
n'avais jamais observée jusque là dans
la société française ou contemporaines
l'image d'un désintéressement complet
vous deviez mourir demain vous
regretteriez ne va pas vécu le côté
lanza del vasto de la vie non je pense
qu'il n'était pas fait pour moi j'en ai
deux ports ging d'autre part bon j'ai eu
une bonne petite existence de deux
journalistes multimédia qui m'a permis
d'avoir droit à une existence à laquelle
ne me destinais
nîmes aisée du limay relation ni mon
physique sur un certain planche quand
même l'impression d'avoir tiré le
maximum du minimum de votre faveur
auprès du temps d'hier est une place
pour dieu il reste en filigrane de tout
ce que je fais le regret de ne pas avoir
eu la foi et leur grève ou six grands de
ne pas avoir rencontré des gens
susceptibles de me communiquer la leur
vous le regrettez oui
oh
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu